[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
lo desconocido fue en el año 86
porque elegir este instrumento
cuatro años desconocía la lectoescritura
papá no me había regalado un vinito de
cola de juguete y automáticamente lo
invertía para usar como acordeón a piano
porque no sé
le insistí a mis viejos que me lleven a
estudiar acordeón no querían porque era
muy chico
fui tan pesado que decidieron llevarme
caigo en el profe de acordeón y me dice
no es muy chico no sé cómo enseñarles
porque no sabe leer no sabe escribir
qué sabe chico no sabe los colores
bueno el proceso de omaña
pinto cada bajo de un color
pinto cada tecla de un color
cada nota tenía un color y así fue que
aprendí a tocar música a los 4 años
por medio de colores y tocabas cosas
sencillas como esta
[Música]
más
así que seguí con el camino del acordeón
seguir con el camino de la música seguía
estudiando la primaria seguía estudiando
trabajé por muchos géneros los básicos
los que por lo general se conocían del
instrumento como la cumbia por ejemplo
[Música]
seguía trabajando la gente por ahí decía
a mis viejos te parece que sigue con el
acordeón te parece que siga con la
música que va a ser de su vida
siempre se cuestionaba porque la música
gracia oídos sordos seguía avanzando
seguía estudiando
y por ahí llega un momento que sentí la
necesidad de mostrar otra cosa porque
porque la gente decía que toca el
acordeón hace cumbia chamamé
si puede ser hacia cosas como esta
[Aplausos]
[Música]
música
[Risas]
[Música]
- editas un clásico del chamamé pero por
ahí sentía la necesidad de hacer otras
cosas hasta que me acuerdo una noche un
programa de bernardo neustad programa
político
tiene una cortina musical que me llamó
la atención y qué música es esa sola era
[Música]
dije ya sola con acordeón nadie lo hacía
creo que mi camino viene por acá la
gente me seguía preguntando haces
conmigo chamamés no estoy haciendo pie a
solas ya sola con acordeón sí
entonces empecé a indagar sobre música
que por ahí no sea ciego en este
instrumento que tenía como una mala fama
y empecé a hacer otra música
hacer otra música como la de piazzolla
medio por ejemplo la satisfacción de
salir campeón argentino de acordeón
salir campeón sudamericano de avión
y el salir campeón sudamericano tocando
algo diferente me lleva al mundial en
italia donde quedó tercero a nivel
mundial desde argentina a italia tocando
persona muy raro no se hacía entonces
dije mi camino va por acá mostrar otras
cosas salir del estereotipo ese decir
esto es para esto este instrumento es
para esta música y mostrar que es un
instrumento multi genérico que se puede
adaptar a muchas cosas
sigue indagando y empiece a ser como las
ideas con acordeón si se puede
[Música]
ah
trabajar
[Risas]
[Música]
entonces seguía con la necesidad de
seguir mostrando otras cosas otra música
la gente seguía diciéndome y de que ibas
a vivir
ya me generaron dudas hasta que decidí
hacer de
mi hermano ingeniero yo con la música de
la gente necesidad que va a servir va a
ser difícil me tiene ingeniería
electromecánica un mejor
cuando empecé a ver autocad dije chau
esto no es para mí con la suerte de que
abre la carrera de musicoterapia para
nada entonces mi carrera sería ligada a
la música gracias a dios hoy soy músico
terapeuta
y bueno seguía seguirá tratando de
mostrar un acordeón diferente mostrar el
instrumento y que se me conozca como
como un acordeonista no una cronista de
determinado género no una correcta de
cumbia una cronista de hecho mediana con
esta de tango sino que como acordeonista
seguía con la necesidad de mostrar cosas
diferentes y surgieron cosas como
michael jackson michael jackson con
acordeón presionado el tango si se puede
[Música]
[Risas]
gracias
seguía con la necesidad de mostrar un
acordeón diferente seguía siempre
gracias a ellos con el apoyo de mis
viejos hasta el día de hoy
y teníamos una fiesta en paraná muy muy
importante que encierra 60.000 80.000
personas y es cómo puedo hacer para que
este para que este instrumento
se conozca con una música diferente en
semejante evento
entonces a lo loco que se le ocurre
hacer música electrónica
música electrónica la fiesta disfraces
[Música]
[Risas]
seguía con la necesidad de mostrar un
acordeón diferente y salir de esa
casilla
de esa mala fama que tenía este
instrumento
un tío me dijo una vez dudando ahí qué
hacer si seguir con la música o estudia
otra cosa me dijo si es lo que realmente
sentís
va a ser tu medio de vida y
definitivamente así fue
desde los 4 años estoy con este
instrumento desde los 4 años trató de
generar otras cosas de salir de lo común
me sigue acompañando con 37 años sigo
estudiando esto nunca se termina y yo
creo que todos en la vida tenemos un
instrumento y está en cada uno saber
cómo utilizarlo y convivir con él de la
mejor manera
hoy este es mi medio de vida
hoy este es mi instrumento y
y esta es una de las músicas que me
acompañan pienso la por ejemplo
[Música]
[Risas]
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
[Música]
para
[Risas]
[Música]
[Aplausos]